it was a very intensive and coordinated
activity by multiple government agencies
in the United States in the UK
requesting censorship on Myriad issues
we mentioned transgenderism climate
change covid was a huge one I mean maybe
the most egregious is where White House
officials demanding that Facebook censor
people for sharing true stories about
vaccine side effects the demand was made
that it'd be censored not because it was
misinformation not because it was
disinformation but because it was true
information that might lead to vaccine
hesitancy to a reluctance on the part of
people to get vaccines so we're we're
now we're in 1984 or well territory so
that's sort of Mal information Mal
information okay true information that's
inconvenient exactly that results in
that make results in behaviors that we
don't like well at that point I mean you
could justify censorship of anything